à partir du 17 mars et jusqu'au 7 avril
15 enfants biélorus qui vont venir en
France des enfants qu'on va lescendre et
défavorisés ils ont entre 8 et 12 ans
ils vivent dans la région contaminée de
Gomel bonsoir au docteur sureau d'être
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau vous
êtes la présidente de l'association
espoir-etcher mobile à Voisins le
bretonneux et c'est grâce à vous grâce à
votre association que ses enfants vont
pouvoir venir dans des familles
d'accueil ils auront tous des familles
d'accueil aujourd'hui vous avez trouvé
des des familles pour les recevoir oui
tout à fait nous avons suffisamment de
famille mais c'est vrai que maintenant
nous avons des groupes plus étroits
qu'il y a une dizaine d'années il est
plus difficile aujourd'hui de les
trouver c'est famille d'accueil sans
sans comparaison absolument qu'est-ce
qui explique je pense que Tchernobyl
c'est loin il y a eu un regain d'intérêt
entre guillemets suite à la catastrophe
de Fukushima mais maintenant
effectivement cette
cette catastrophe à plus de 20 ans et
donc nous avons de plus en plus de
difficultés à avoir la des gens
disponibles alors ces enfants qui vont
venir en France et qui viennent depuis
une vingtaine d'années l'association que
vous avez fondé a été fondée il y a une
vingtaine d'années déjà en 1990
exactement
les enfants qui vont venir sont là pour
justement penser à autre chose ils sont
là aussi pour des soins qu'est-ce qui me
motivent la venue de ces enfants alors
dans les enfants qui viennent dans les
15 pour aucun a de soins sur place par
contre ce sont des enfants qui sont
convalescents donc ils ont tous eu une
leucémie un cancer et ils ont besoin
effectivement de chaleur de bonheur et
de manger autre chose que de la
nourriture contaminée puisque ce sont
tous des enfants qui vivent dans la
région de Gomel alors on voit quelques
images non pas de la région de gommel
mais la région elle a pris tripiade
pardon donc du côté de Tchernobyl des
images à l'heure actuelle de cette de
cette ville fantôme 30 ans bientôt après
la catastrophe la région est toujours
contaminée il y a toujours des
conséquences vous le disiez tout à
l'heure en introduction on en parle
peut-être moins ça paraît très loin mais
aujourd'hui encore le site est contaminé
toute la région est contaminé oui de
Pripiat et interdite à la population
quoi que certaines personnes y soient
retournées pour y vivre mais surtout
d'autres régions qui sont habitées comme
la région de Gomel en Biélorussie et
sont tout à fait contaminés et les gens
mangent les produits de cette terre donc
il a des conséquences sanitaires sur la
santé de toutes les personnes qui
résidents mais personne n'a accès aux
informations bien entendu en Biélorussie
comme en Russie les informations ne
filent pas dans la mesure où il n'y
avait pas de registre précédent nous
avons nous n'avons pas de moyens de
comparer les choses ceci étant nous
savons que certaines pathologies qui
sont développées 4 à 5 ans après la
catastrophe comme des cancers de la
thyroïde chez l'enfant qui n'existent
pas dans des régions non contaminées ce
sont développés accrus et maintenant on
diminué et nous n'en avons que très peu
maintenant quelles sont les maladies
aujourd'hui les plus fréquentes et qui
sont développées justement que vous
évoquiez ce sont surtout des carences en
vitamines des carences face aux maladies
immunitaire ou infectieuse et des
cancers ou des leucémies est-ce que vous
mettez en avant via votre site internet
ou j'invite les téléspectateurs à se
rendre pour avoir beaucoup plus
d'informations l'adresse va s'afficher
ainsi qu'un numéro de téléphone c'est ce
témoignage ce témoignage recueillant
Biélorussie les biélorusses qui
déclarent qu'ils vivent quelque chose de
pire que la guerre parce que là c'est
totalement invisible et inconnu des
témoignages que vous avez entendus
recueilli vous êtes rendu des fois aussi
oui oui je suis allé très régulièrement
j'y vais moins maintenant d'autres
personnes de l'association Yvon mais ce
sont des témoignages poignants parce que
les gens vivent ça comme une injustice
et ils sont très touchés de voir des
personnes qui s'intéressent à leur sort
et se sentent extrêmement isolés face à
cette menace invisible donc ça veut dire
que si psychologiquement ce sont des
populations très fragiles ah oui tout à
fait parce qu'il y a cette menace au
quotidien et que ça empêche de vivre
tout simplement normalement complètement
l'OMS a d'ailleurs reconnu cette
difficulté psychologique qui a un
retentissement sur le corps la situation
à l'heure actuelle avec la création d'un
nouveau sarcophage qui a d'ailleurs
longtemps traîné il a été difficile de
mobiliser des fonds et récemment on en a
reparlé dans l'actualité de Tchernobyl
pas seulement parce que c'est aussi
l'anniversaire de la catastrophe de
Fukushima mais aussi parce que au moment
des travaux du sarcophage qui les
travaux qui se poursuivent il y a un
toit dans bâtiment annexe qui s'était
fondé aussi et des inquiétudes qui sont
resurgies vous êtes inquiète aussi vous
pour la population qui est sur place et
éventuellement des de des choses qu'on
ne saurait pas et des inquiétudes qu'on
pourrait avoir avec de nouvelles
contaminations alors Tchernobyl est en
Ukraine donc c'est un petit peu
différent effectivement de la
Biélorussie on a davantage
d'informations néanmoins il est certain
que tout ne filtre pas bien sûr il peut
persister une inquiétude sans être trop
énorme non plus parce que la communauté
internationale donne de l'argent pour le
sarcophage mais surveille quand même les
travaux mais il a été difficile de
retenir de retrouver tous ces fonds
justement pour permettre la construction
du sarcophage ça a beaucoup traîné à
l'époque avait été construit dans
l'urgence tout le monde le dit tous les
spécialistes le disent et puis il a
fallu attendre bientôt 30 ans pour que
des nouveaux travaux débutent pour
isoler ce réacteur qui avait explosé
vous vous agacez comment vous réagissez
quand vous voyez que les politiques
peut-être parfois ont du mal à mettre la
main à la poche sur des dossiers si
important pour protéger aussi des
populations oui je crois qu'on peut
naître kagacées effectivement c'est
c'est fort dommage
mais ce n'est pas le seul scandale avec
les politiques malheureusement
au-delà de tout ça il y a une
manifestation ce week-end des opposants
au nucléaires qui ont manifesté à
travers Paris qui ont créé une chaîne de
solidarité pour dénoncer l'aptitude
aussi des politiques qui continuent à
développer le nucléaire vous les
soutenez vous les comprenez en tout cas
je crois que je les comprends maintenant
nous avons dès le départ fonder
l'association sur un contexte de prise
de position que nous ne ferons pas face
au nucléaire néanmoins le nucléaire est
fort utile mais fort dangereux donc je
crois qu'il faut avoir une attitude
raisonnable et essayer d'envisager des
catastrophes puisque nous voyons
aujourd'hui quels sont toujours possible
et que elles ont une ampleur énorme et
malheureusement l'exemple de kushima est
vraiment fort inquiétant ne voulait pas
prendre position en tout cas sur l'arrêt
ou non du nucléaire donc médecin aussi
non parce que je connais aussi en tant
que médecin justement les bons côtés du
nucléaire d'application absolument
au-delà des catastrophes qui font
forcément toujours la une et qui font
forcément aussi beaucoup de dégâts et
c'est pour ça que vos associations sont
très importantes pour aider toutes ces
différentes populations face aux abus
aux excès qui ont été ont pu être ont pu
être fait au manque de sécurité sur
certaines zones comment vous intervenez
aussi d'une autre manière parce que les
enfants viennent en France on en a parlé
tout à l'heure mais il y a d'autres
actions que vous menez aussi vous
envoyer du matériel médical par exemple
tout à fait nous aidons les médecins et
les soignants sur place nous prenons un
médecin en formation à l'occasion du
séjour des enfants parce qu'ils ont
besoin de formation complémentaires et
nous avons une petite fille qui revient
pour la deuxième fois qui a été opérée
d'une malformation grave et qui vient
donc pour envisager la deuxième phase de
l'opération elle elle vient en plus du
groupe parce que il faut qu'elle reste à
chaque fois davantage pour avoir des
soins en collaboration avec des médecins
bénévoles vous savez combien d'enfants
vous avez réussi à aider depuis une
vingtaine d'années que l'association
existe mais j'aurais dû à tenir les
chiffres c'est sûr plus de 1000
probablement plus de Demi et plus de
2000 pardon mais effectivement
au travers d'un enfant nous aidons toute
une famille les frères et sœurs les
grands-parents c'est une action en fait
qui fait tâche d'huile il y a des
contextes que vous gardez toujours
toujours les familles gardent des
contacts pas toutes bien sûr les
familles gardent du contact nous nous
avons des contacts avec l'association
qui nous choisit les enfants et nous
suivons toujours ce que deviennent ces
enfants nombre sont des jeunes
maintenant ont un travail et nous avons
toujours des lettres de remerciement via
Facebook parce qu'ils nous retrouvent
via facebook pour certains qui avaient
été perdu de vue et envoie des messages
extrêmement touchants de combien
l'intervention de l'association a été
utile dans leur vie qu'est-ce qui a
motivé la création de votre association
un appel un appel d'une personne
ukrainienne au départ rencontrer à
l'occasion d'une course de voile et
c'est ça c'est un déclic que vous avez
eu où vous a dit il faut qu'on les aide
il faut qu'on crée une structure pour
les aider faire venir ses enfants aller
les aider aussi sur place tout à fait
nous avions conscience que les
politiques ne pouvaient pas tout faire
et que le terrain était totalement miné
et nous nous sommes dit avec quelques
amis que là on pouvait intervenir au
plus près des familles ça a été notre
souhait de ne pas fonctionner dans ce
qui est étatique mais de fonctionner
plutôt sur le médical sur le social ça a
toujours été la ligne de l'association
et je pense que c'est une ligne
que nous allons continuer parce que
c'est là qu'on aide vraiment les gens au
plus près il n'y a aucune déperdition
d'argent si vous vouliez passer un
message ce soir s'il y avait un message
important à faire passer ce serait quoi
de ne pas oublier ses enfants voilà et
de nous rejoindre d'aller sur le site
d'imprimer le bulletin d'adhésion et de
nous rejoindre plus nous serons plus
nous aurons de force et donc une
quinzaine d'enfants biélorusse qui vont
venir en France à partir du 17 mars ils
sont dans le département des Yvelines où
c'est à travers
le reste de la France grâce à votre
association espoir Adja mobile le site
internet le numéro de téléphone qui
s'est affiché merci au Docteur suero
d'être venu sur ce plateau parler de son
action engagée quasiment roulant de
cette catastrophe de Tchernobyl dans 86
nous continuons le 7 8 en ce 13 mars la
chronique culture dans un instant avec
Aurélia Debussy le temps d'un détour par
Versailles capitale du jeu vidéo le
temps d'une soirée